Speaker 1: I want to play a clip for you today
of a Fox News guest sort of giving away the game,
giving away the strategy when it comes to the
anti-mask protests. There's this guy David Avella,
who's the chairman of Go Pack, GOP Pack, Go Pack,
OK. He was a guest on Fox News, and he essentially
admits to what these wild protests are at school
board meetings, what they're really designed to
do, and why they're being urged on by right wing
media and right wing activists and strategists.
They want to make public school seem so chaotic
that parents will say, I'm pulling my kid out,
I'm going to send them to a private school and
send them to a charter school. It's similar to
the strategy around making the Postal Service
really not function properly. We'll get to that.
Let's start with the clip. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: He brought to this conversation makes
me think maybe she'll run for
school board and we might be.
Speaker 1: So right now, they're praising
some outrageous lunatic woman who was
screaming her mouth, you know, screaming her
head off at a school board meeting teacher.
Speaker 3: So I don't know about that.
Speaker 4: I actually elected to be
the class teacher to my sixth grader,
and I don't know what I was thinking.
Speaker 2: But this is going to be a boon for our
boom for private schools, for charter schools,
for home schoolers. You are going to look for
an alternative other than in the public school,
and there are plenty of wonderful organizations
out there that provide scholarships for kids to go
to charter schools.
Speaker 1: And and by the way,
it's entirely an apparatus that takes
money away from public schools as well.
Speaker 2: And what we're going to
start seeing is once again, democratic
politicians policies are going to hurt the
very people they think they are going to help,
which is in many of our poor and rural
communities all across this country. And
to Jenna's point, you ask most everyday teachers,
they want to teach their kids the basics,
reading, writing rhythm tech so that they're
ready to go out and compete in a world
where China is not teaching the agenda.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there's actually a question mark
as to whether the standard curriculum is actually
preparing our kids. That different question.
But he's saying the quiet part out loud here.
He's saying the quiet part. This has been
the Republican agenda. This has been the DeSantis
agenda for a long time in Florida as well weaken
public schools in favor of corporate owned
schools, charter schools, private schools, etc..
And one way to do it is creating requirements that
make the schools look bad, either through testing,
standardized testing, different things
to then say the school is not working,
let's take money away. Let's give vouchers to
people who want to send their kids to a private
or charter school instead, so you make the schools
worse to then justify making them even worse.
This is a very it's like a perfect opportunity.
Make it seem crazy. Parents here? Oh my god,
there's anti-mask protesters outside of the
school when my kids are showing up, and then
there's anti-mask protesters taking over the
school. This is too crazy. I'm going to send my
kids to a charter school, to a private school. I'm
going to homeschool them. Remember, something like
70 percent of American homeschooling is Christian
based and for religious and moral reasons.
Mission accomplished. This is exactly the plan,
and the bigger picture here is privatization.
That's the bigger picture. Destroy. Why do they
want to make the Postal Service function like
crap? Because then you can justify eliminating
it altogether and saying, let's just let actual.
Private industry, even though the Postal Service
is an independent enterprise under the purview
of the federal government, they don't want the
government doing stuff right. That's socialism.
When the government does stuff, it's socialism,
even if it's just oversight of an independent
Postal Service. So then people go FedEx, they go
UPS, DHL, et cetera, damage the Postal Service
to justify private replacements, damage public
schools to justify sending more money to private
schools and charter schools, et cetera. And
they now are making these anti-mask protesters
out to be martyrs or victims or whatever the
case may be now. And let's just look at one
clip of that real quick. This is also during the
same program, Kennedy saying, you're going to be
targeted for passionately raising your voice.
Speaker 2: We need to focus on the basics.
And that's not what's happening right now.
Speaker 4: Can I can I add something very quickly,
Emily? Of course, you're more likely to be
targeted and charged by the FBI for raising
your voice passionately at a school board meeting
than you are for trying to set a federal building
on fire with people inside in Portland, Oregon.
Speaker 1: Right? They're basically saying just
protesting about masks is more likely to get
you treated harshly by law enforcement than
antifa setting fires in Portland, Oregon. That's
the case that they want to make the game here is
privatization. David Avella, they're saying the
quiet part out loud. We we know what they're doing
and also it's the moralizing and the engaging
people with the most controversial stuff they can.
And right now, masking and vaccination is exactly
what that is. They're admitting it. They're
telling us that that's why they're doing it.
Tuesday, October 19th, 6:00 PM Eastern Time We'll
be our live viewer town hall. It'll be streaming
only on the second YouTube channel Pacman Live
at YouTube.com slash Pacman Live. Everybody will
be allowed to call in. Members will get priority,
but it'll be wide open to everybody. I hope you'll
join us. Remember that The David Pakman Show does
depend on the few of you. Comparatively speaking,
who get a membership at join Packman dot com, you
can sign up, become a member, support the
show and of course, get instant access to
the Daily Bonus Show for members
only. Sign up at join Pacman dot com!